infinity war is the greatest movie ever
made not superhero movie not [ __ ] any
uh it's the put it up against anything
it's the number one movie and it's the
peak of cinema and they will never make
anything better there will never be a
better movie experience there'll never
be a better overall story there'll never
be a better anything this is the one
before end game are you including it no
i do not including it in games just a
superhero movie
this is infinity war is a movie and it's
better than shawshank it's better to
[ __ ] name a movie bro
the prequel to i am sam
literally one of the best i'm going to
be saying i'm going to be saying
that's an awesome oh and when you see
that [ __ ] sperm swim back in his
dick
what are you doing like it is pretty
[ __ ] special that movie you got to
see that [ __ ]
that is that was the downside of
swimming yeah the point of the two
cousins [ __ ] yeah yeah it's twelve
and a half percent yeah yeah
okay but uh infinity war is
the first part of
the the avengers the la the final
avengers which is infinity war in game
and the reason it's the best movie of
all time start start at the end they
lose that's what makes it already top
top-notch
or other things you know reservoir dogs
or movies like that pulp fiction where
it's like nothing there's no winner
nobody wins the best movie you can't win
you can't walk out feeling good you got
to walk out feeling got to walk out
thinking
you know what i'm saying
in infinity war you cry it starts
amazing if there is no breaks they they
exactly pace it's the most it's the best
pace movie i've ever seen in my life in
the first five seconds of the movie the
hulk is getting his ass beat the hulk so
you're already like whether you know
anything about superheroes or not you
know like the beginning is fire that's
the whole time
when thanos gets [ __ ] up a little bit
and then a guy's going to step in he
goes no no let him have this fun that's
what i'm saying that's fine
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying there's
never been a better movie and there will
be
two for three three for three but yeah
you just you're convinced now best movie
ever wait i'm trying to think best movie
ever is that better than shawshank
redemption absolutely he wins
dusty is great his whole life he spends
getting yeah he got [ __ ] by dudes many
times yeah that's a tough one
his
like he's pretty some would say like the
final outcome is like he's gotta live in
mexico on a boat and he swam through
actual doo-doo to get there yeah yeah
all that oh that's great but you don't
cry you didn't cry don't cry
you don't cry
yeah you're um bro who when he reveals
that he he broke out you're not like
like you you're not crying you're just
like i stood up i watched in the [ __ ]
room about the movie by myself like a
loser stood up raised my arms like a
biggest dork that's not crying that's
the same feeling that rudy gets you
that's winning
celebratory i was like yo i'm not having
sex for a long time but this is so fine
what part what part when you when he
gets free and you see like how it all
happened you're like oh this
[ __ ] were you just excited that
he was swimming through [ __ ] like it was
relatable to you like
so like the godfather like it's not
better than god
no godfather is great but no the
infinity war is the greatest movie of
all time because you cry bro spiderman
dies you start crying for everyone in
the theater also i include theater
experience mr stark
mr stewart
yeah
doesn't even count bro there's [ __ ]
like oh there was 13 people in the
theater shut the [ __ ] up sold out five
seven weeks in a row every seat filled
everybody reacting the same way that is
an experience that was a [ __ ]
movement bro like infinity war and in
games only everyone's like oh in game
that's only because of infinity war
that's that's that was just you you are
you had to like
you came and you already have to like
you know well actually no infinity war
is all the [ __ ] end games coming um
the best part is i mean it actually
depends what you like but i like the
[ __ ] part
i like the [ __ ] no you know what i mean
coming it's over yeah
you know what i'm saying so that's why
infinity war it's just pound for pound
the greatest movie ever made okay okay
acting cast the cast is insane i mean
bro it's perfect
do you think it has good representation
from minorities and disabled people dude
black panther's in it captain marvel's
in it one black dude a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's get him
come on she shouldn't beat me but i'll
let her be here
i'll let her in this wait what's your
return
game right
oh actually you're right she's not an
infinity war yeah that's why it's so
good
that's why it's a perfect [ __ ] movie
guys thank you so much for watching that
flagrant two clip but before you go i
gotta tell you about blue chew you need
to deliver the woman you care about the
best dick that you can possibly give her
and the way you're going to do that is
with blue chew you don't want to be like
certain djs out here find out you've
been married to a girl for 10 years and
then she never came no you cannot do
that so get blue chew give her the best
dick you can possibly give her and the
way you do that is by going to
bluechew.com and entering the promo code
andrew and they will give you your first
order for free all you got to do is pay
five dollars shipping again that is
bluechew.com promo code andrew now go
watch another flagrant 2 clip